for tens of thousands of Ukrainian
soldiers
and since last February NATO allies had
delivered more than
150 billion euros of support
including 65 billion of military aid
this has enabled your troops
to force yourself out of here Hanson and
high cape
allies are now delivering more Jets
tanks and armored vehicles
an angel's Ukraine fund is providing
urgent support
including medical supplies more
satellite systems and platoon Bridges
all of this is making a real difference
on the battlefield every day
we do not know when this war will end
but we know that Russian aggression is a
toxic pattern that must be stopped
we agreed on the importance of a just
unsustainable peace
and I strongly welcome
president zlenskies his plan
we must continue to strengthening
Ukraine's Armed Forces
and we must ensure that robust powerful
arrangements are in place
for Ukraine's security
let me be clear
Ukraine's rightful place is in the Euro
Atlantic family
Ukraine's rightful place is in nature
and over time our support will help you
make this possible
to the end the president and I discussed
a multi-year support initiative
this will help you transition from
Soviet air equipment and doctrines to
Nato standards and ensure full
interoperability with the alarms
it is a testament to NATO's long-term
commitment Ukraine
NATO stands with you today tomorrow and
for as long as it takes
thank you again for hosting me here
today I look forward to welcome you to
the NATO Summit in Venus in July
um